good morning John it's Wednesday and I
have got a lot of weird to share with
you today just to start this out I
wanted to say that I completely agree
with you we require more vespene gas
some of the best things in the world are
done simply because they're the best
things in the world
things like lolcat san 4chan not to be
too immodest nerdfighters I'll kind of
hang from loose in the mouth do you
think we're not creating for money they
were not created for fame or power that
were created with the goal of awesome in
mind just like Gary Busey family
portrait just like this picture of Mount
Rushmore from behind the world is a
better place because people just like
awesome that just really excites me that
there are so many people in the world
who are just inspired to be awesome by
awesome you know there's a lot of
reasons to do stuff that is a boss
Zefron poster rock on you can do to
become things you can do it because you
believe in something and of course you
can do it to try and make money but the
only real reason to do something is
because it makes you excited because you
love that thing like the way I love
making videos and I'm not even excited
yet the way that I can go to a party
store and pay nine bucks for a set of
clown hands because I want to say hey
surprise clown hand the way I could just
put duct tape on my face
Wow for you cuz I like it a part where
my mouth got really big was really cool
I want to do it again aside from the
pain it's a really unique experience oh
that wasn't too bad I was sweating a
little bit underneath so it was gonna do
sanded off but still dingy anybody want
this it's got I sweat on it let's be
honest right now your life is a little
bit better than it was before I put the
two candles on and now your life is
little bit better than it was when I was
wearing the two candles as a nose and
not as a horn I'm gonna be making the
lives better well and let me tell you
that squirrel did not enjoy my presence
in his dance club because you are making
my life better
let me tell you something else I have
people to give me weird things to say in
a video on Twitter and you've been
hearing those all throughout the video I
am the best crab fisherman that ever
lived
what are you gonna do about it I now in
the instigator of one of the world's
largest databases of random sentences
that may not actually be true but maybe
it is maybe it is it's really steamy in
there I'm gonna put this little cowboy
hat on again I think it was my favorite
thing so far
Chris Crocker is so pretty creating
things because you think they're awesome
is always a good thing to do for your
future that is undeniable because if you
think they're awesome then other people
are going to think they're awesome too
especially if you are like the majority
of people which you know you might not
be but look neither am i and i think
this is awesome
maybe you do too most people aren't
gonna think this is awesome they're
gonna think it's dumb hands are getting
really sweaty
Oh summertime is not the time for clown
gloves there's nothing wrong with doing
stuff just because it's awesome
in fact there's everything right with
doing stuff just because it's awesome so
let's keep it up because it's working
I'm kind of hanging some listen about
the times if you want to call don't
bother
destructors make you salivate and the
quality around it all they do and now
these are wet